i fell asleep in the bath bombs with a
nosebleed and it was uh scary waking up
to that you know we ever fell asleep in
the bath
no that's how people die no it was like
a shallow bath
you can still die
hello and welcome to the trash taste
podcast this is now
episode 2 hopefully unless some
unless we [ __ ] up unless we [ __ ] up
somehow i am your host for the day
gigguk and joining me is connor from
cr
[Music]
va and joey from the anime man hi
well that's a lot more energetic than
last time right yeah well
i just like came in nonchalantly
i should be like that because i'm gonna
say right now apologies
if i'm a bit out of it i'm slightly
hungover because it was my birthday
celebrations yesterday so how old are
you 47
i am well in in youtube years yes
because i've been around since the
beginning of youtube
basically but no i've uh finally hit my
dirty 30s oh my god
that's scary i know i always forget
the huge like age gap between us yeah
yeah because between
conor and gand there's seven years seven
years
20 30 a.m that's that's [ __ ] insane i
forget all the time that you are
everyone thinks i'm like 30 especially
in japan everyone yeah yeah i mean it's
the beard
beard you immediately have like four
mortgages a car and two kids
but because it is or it was gone's
birthday i got him
a gift i wonder what this could be i
wonder
it's manga see we've just reached that
age you know where this
this is just a acceptable gift that you
can give anyone yeah
um so let's let's let's do the unboxing
shall we
yes asmr asmr unboxing time
yeah and you see we've already got wine
glasses because we had no idea what this
could possibly be
it is fancy so basically at our
supermarket i'll
tell the story while you're opening that
so basically at the supermarket that we
all
live near which i'm not gonna say yeah
uh there's like a
like a boost section like a liquor store
section and i didn't know for the
longest time that not only is there a
liquor sauce section but there's like
a dedicated section to wine okay like a
wine
like room i guess so i got a uh
an italian one i think overall
i i misread this at first i was like
buruto
like i was like this is this anime one
naruto
borrows so wide yeah it just sounds like
a generic dragon ball villain
thank you very much no worries i don't
know too much about wines apart from if
they're in
um red or white what colors
if they're red or white or if they're
one of the ten from drops of god
i don't think it's that but barolo is
like uh i think it's like pretty well
known in
italy i think right the guy was like oh
yeah if you want like a well-known
italian wine like get barolo so uh
hey if anyone's watching this episode or
listening to this episode
probably you're italian let us know if
you know
barolo i just thought they were like the
[ __ ] is a barolo
rolo that's what they call boruto
actually it's funny because how i got
into wine
because how i got into wine initially
was literally um
drops of god because before that i was
like why does anyone would drink wine i
just want a cold beer
i don't want to like but after reading
you read drops of god once and you're
like i love wine
wine's great i i read drops of god on a
flight
i think it was what was the flight i
don't know it's from like america or
somewhere
and uh i remembered reading drops of god
and you know when like the little cart
comes by yeah what do you want to drink
and i was like
of course i want what i'm a connoisseur
of fine taste
of course why even ask me the question
yeah i was about to ask i hope you were
drinking
wine on the flight away so so she you
know she gets out there the little
bottle of wine they crack open and pours
it into this plastic cup for me
and it was like the most pathetic drink
i'd ever had i was sitting there like
swirling this plastic cup that like a
you know ten-year-old would drink a
drink out yeah yeah just mean that
yeah that's good yeah because table wine
we all know table wine on flights is
basically just like
grape juice with hand sanitizer in it
like it's it's disgusting i mean because
you you can't even taste
uh like things that aren't like super
salty right on flights anyway yeah
i feel like wine is the worst thing i
feel like it's that point when you're
watching something that's
super good like for example when you're
watching shokugeki
this food looks amazing and you're
sitting there with your [ __ ] takeaway
combining meal
and you're like this is this is kind of
like a5b
now just imagine hard enough
nothing more orgasmic than craft mac and
cheese
[Music]
oh
which was another meme that uh
originated from drops of god
if if oh come on i'm sorry
okay
the podcast is starting now happy
birthday cheers
so boys what are we what are we
discussing today what's the topic i mean
on the topic of you know we we talked
about
uh we because we live quite close
together right we live within
you know walking distance yeah so i
guess
i think a good topic would be how we you
know what our experiences are like
living here in japan
now that we've all finally moved here
because we just moved here um how many
months have we been living here now it's
actually like eight
eight months she's crazy really yeah
yeah october so
it's just hit june so it was like and
this was like middle too it was like
seven and a half months i guess yeah
yeah right
yeah and that's it does not feel like no
no well to be fair the last two months i
might as well have been living in
[ __ ] australia
i like quarantine does things to you and
i hadn't heard anyone speak japanese
yeah like
about two months except for like that
brief moment where you'd go out to buy
groceries and you i just forget that i
was living in japan
yeah legit like i remember like catching
the train for the first time in like
two months and i was just like the world
is full of water
i was like i felt like i was uh like
cast away like
when he like tom hanks after castaway
when he came back to humanity
you know because i don't i don't know if
you guys have but yet but i still
haven't gone into tokyo yet
uh uh i went there like central tokyo
yeah yeah i think the first time i went
there was like
yesterday and that was literally just
because it was like quarantine was over
just on like the day of my birthday yeah
yeah
oh this is this is fate i'm i'm gonna go
out and uh have some nice food but
even now there's like a lot of places
are still closed yeah so it's it's still
not like everything's open yet
um but yeah it's it's been a really
fast eight months it hasn't felt like
eight years at all
like i guess my first question to you
guys my first question to you guys is
like what
made you decide to move to japan in the
first place because you've been here for
how many years now
i've been here four years now yeah i
guess for you it's more obvious though
i mean yeah because i've spent what like
half my life here and i have family
up north and in tokyo um at least with
me
like i'm pretty sure i've said this in
videos before but like
i was gonna move to japan after i
graduated from uni anyway
because i i think this was like back
when i had
maybe like 20k 30k subs so i wasn't
doing it full time at all
yeah i was in like my second year of
university and i was
interning at like a japanese like it
company which i believe
is now like defunct like it doesn't
exist anymore i don't think
so glad that internship never went
through yeah but
yeah so i i was gonna move to japan
anyway because like it just makes sense
for me because i'm fluent in both
english and japanese which is
such a huge plus here like if you know
both languages like
you can pretty much get a job anywhere
we'll we'll get to that yeah
we'll get to that and like no one in
australia gives a [ __ ] if you can speak
japanese
yeah exactly like my dad's works at like
a japanese it company for
30 years he can't speak a word in
japanese yeah it's because no one in the
office can speak japanese right but
here it's like if you can speak english
you can do business with
anybody yeah in or out of japan so it
just was like a natural process for me
to like okay
i get my paper i work at like some
[ __ ] it company in japan and then
we're all good so yeah it's funny
because i i reckon one of the
few industries where japanese is it can
be super super important
is anime and manga exactly exactly yeah
you might start your luck there yeah
exactly so like either way
like it was just a natural like path for
me to like move here
yeah but you know instead of you know
doing that desk job that i
had set my plans on uh you know youtube
for me blew up like in my third year of
uni when i graduated and so
i was like all right i'll guess i'll do
this guess i'll do youtube for as long
as i can and then
you're still doing it i'm still doing it
somehow i'm still doing it
i know it's crazy the story of or i
guess like the the original plan
that was brought up to you guys about
bbq yes like a year ago
yeah because i wanted to move here for a
while i remember
like since we first met each other and
since my first trip to japan i was like
i could really see myself living here
this is and this is not
like the typical weeb kind of fantasy
i actually never had that you know i was
what like i remember
back in back in the day when it was like
mid-2000s yeah
like the weeaboo dream was to live in
japan and you know
work in the anime work in the anime
industry it was just like a [ __ ]
dream that nobody had ever proven or you
know
so it was just that weeb dream but i
never really wanted that i was like you
know i'm i'm happy with a normal career
yeah um i'd never really fantasized
about going to japan but
i remember the first time i came here it
was so eye-opening for me because it was
like
you know when you know that feeling when
you're like man this country just works
in a lot of ways and it's to do with my
job
so i'm like this this could be a really
good opportunity for me yeah
i definitely felt the same thing with
how i thought about japan
yeah i i couldn't have cared less about
living here and i thought people were
learning the language
at the time you know i was like 15 14 i
was like that's kind of cringe bro
but like now now that you know i've
actually started to learn it i regret it
so much i regret that like
i didn't learn any because i could have
been like a few months ahead at least
right
i wish i was more weeaboo yeah like now
that the
now that the cringy weeaboo phase is
over i wish i was that cringey weeaboo
because that would give me so much more
of an advantage
now that i'm hearing yeah yeah exactly
you know and
a part of me with i remember when i i
used to think that way like anyone who's
learning it it's just like wow it's so
sad you're never like actually gonna
learn it but like to be fair if you're
learning anything
you know any other kind of language
especially if you only speak one i think
that's like
good good on you like better yourself
you know gives a [ __ ] and i really
regret that i thought that
everyone everyone who's learning
japanese because of anime is pathetic
like yeah but then again i was like an
edgy teenager right and we all think
that and
yeah like like like you said i had no i
no intention or want to live here
yeah i was pretty content in the uk and
even when i visited here i thought
wow this is an amazing place to come
visit right but
i don't think i was still sold yet on
moving here because i
i think i don't know about you guys but
i really like need friends
[Music]
and i was like i need that social
interaction
for every weeb but i i do need like to
have friends
that i like see often otherwise like i
really get like upset like you're like
the antithesis of
every weirdo yeah like i i need to
socialize or i
really like it really starts to take a
toll on me yeah i was just like
i really like worried that i wouldn't be
able to you know have a good social
circle or meet people
yeah i mean luckily that hasn't been the
case but because i guess the big
difference between you and me is that
i've already like before japan i'd
already lived in thailand
for right right three years um so i had
experience
moving to a different country and
finding new friends
and to me it was like okay that's i'm
just starting the process
all over again and it's just a new
adventure i guess yeah
so it was a lot easier for me to decide
hey i'm gonna i'm gonna move to japan i
guess the biggest thing
that's you know made me think is that do
i really want to go
through this process again how long do i
see myself actually living here
yeah um and to me it was like this is
the last big move
i'm gonna do before i kind of start to
think about yeah that's crazy
staying in one place just flying to
different countries every few months
which is what i was doing
before yeah yeah i i don't know how you
were doing that for like
yeah like it was because you were you
were going from like thailand to uk
to america america and then yeah it was
it wasn't
it was like i had three offices i had
one in thailand one in the uk
and one in america that's a major
entrepreneur
it's like the traveling just gets to you
man because i oh yeah
like you know when you're like at
university you're like i just want to
travel i want to
get out i want to experience new things
but you do it every year for about a
good
four years and it [ __ ] it [ __ ]
gets you in yeah
yeah i think i'm definitely starting to
phase out of that like i love
just any excuse to travel is great
because now i'm really starting to like
to test
some some travel remember like when
traveling to anime cons was exciting
and now the thought of having to go on a
plane to get somewhere
that was to me to me it's it's a lot
harder than it used to be
i guess because it's just because how
it's become
it's always a 10 plus hour flight and
that's like the thing
that is really draining we must sound so
god i'm so annoyed we have to travel so
it's i hate to win these concerts pay
for our travel
right but yeah i mean you know it's i
guess it happens right when you travel a
[ __ ] ton i'm sure any anyone who has
like parents or family
friends who work their whole business is
to travel it does become drainage
i mean because it's it is a job i think
yeah because i like you know
it's people want to travel but if you've
ever had like a
office job which i did for the bbc and
you had to travel
to europe you have to travel to these
places and it's just
hours and hours of traveling for the job
it drains you
no matter where you're traveling to if
you travel there enough it'll
it'll eventually drain you and it will
there's a massive difference between
traveling for
pleasure oh yeah for business and i mean
like it doesn't seem
it might not seem there's like a huge
difference especially to someone who
doesn't travel
a lot but after a while you're just like
oh man i have to go on this flight
versus
yay i get to go on this flight i think
the only time i'm like excited for a
flight is when like
netflix drops like a whole show yeah
that i'm like super hyped for
it's like yeah sweet like at 10 hours no
one bothered me yeah i haven't watched
this hell yeah that's like the only time
but the worst is when you get to the app
you're like [ __ ] i didn't download
anything yeah
oh god oh no we have to pay for shitty
wi-fi to scroll on twitter for 12 hours
cool i have to play this solitaire game
for 10 hours that doesn't require any
internet yeah it's like when you sit
down for a [ __ ] and you realize your
phone's on one percent
you're like what do i do when this
battery runs out
like another thing is like time
differences and yeah adjusting sleep
schedule
i got a question for you because we went
through the same kind of flight how did
you
find the traveling to the crunchyroll
anime awards because to put things in
perspective we
we had we were there for like one day
one two two days
right um and we had to travel how long
did you have to travel
16 ish hours i think it was for the
crunchyroll anime awards yeah for me it
was 21 hours of traveling
yeah because you're in the uk at the
time i was in thailand
which is even worse yeah that was the
straw that broke the camel's back
after that i was like right you know if
if i'm traveling too far
there's got to be something man i think
i remember hanging out with you after
you came back from that and you were
still pissed off about like
that you had to endure that and i'm like
all right well you know
i just want to say cheers you're all for
not inviting me to that
you saved me a lot of trouble no i mean
it's a great experience
yeah i'm trying to i'm trying to be
brand uh friendly here
my brand like i'm not saying the
experience is bad
what i'm the the thing that was bad was
me having to adjust
immediately to uh to like a 16 hour time
difference
and then two days later have to adjust
back yeah and try to be
in like try to be in a working state not
to mention in between that you have to
go on stage in front of
thousands of people yeah and be like
yeah yeah just just just nail this don't
act like you're sleepy
yeah yeah no pressure it was fun overall
i like uh networking with people and
like meeting other youtubers you don't
get to see often is
pretty fun but anyway cycling back to
the japan stuff
when in your timeline did you
get like i guess presented with the idea
or the offer of moving
like when was that or do you remember
the date ish i can't
remember the dates the exact time and
location
roughly um when was it for you because i
i know that you knew you were like the
offer had been presented itself to you
before me
um and i think it must have been like
in either like february march-ish this
is like
it was like three or four months before
ax i know that yeah when i
i remember it was like at least a year
ago when i heard about it yeah
yeah so it was i think i guess from the
timeline where it came up to me knowing
it was possibility
to me actually like finishing the move
it was probably like like seven eight
months oh yeah it's it's been
it's been well over a year for me
because i
knew that you knew before me so yeah how
it happened for me was i was i remember
i was just sitting in a book walker
meeting
and we were just talking about i can't
remember some some random stuff about
what book walker you know wants to do in
the future and then
um the person who i was talking to which
is
can i can i mention your name alan
i'm not going to throw i'm not going to
throw you on there
so so melin who is basically our manager
we're all our managers now um she
basically just asked me
have you ever thought about moving to
japan
and that was just kind of a this it just
kind of came out of nowhere for me yeah
i was like i didn't know how to react to
that
i was like that's a loaded question yeah
um but
i mean i'm not gonna say no but you know
you know when you like
ask the question and it's obviously for
a purpose like it's not just it's not a
hypothetical yeah yeah yeah and you're
like
oh this this this could actually be a
thing yeah and so
um i went away i thought about it and i
was like
yeah if i'm not gonna do it now then
when in my life am i gonna do it
yeah yeah yeah and then i guess the idea
just grew from there from
what if like from it being a
hypothetical question to
what needs to happen to be able to bring
an annie tuber
to japan as a job yeah right right right
and so that started
my whole process when did you when did
you hear about it uh yeah i think it was
it must have been around march february
i'm not 100 sure i
i think i was i think i was on call with
maylene i think maylene brought it up to
me
and and was basically the same thing
where it's like the
hypothetical do you like japan or
something like that right and i think i
was just like
oh wait or maybe i was in japan at the
time
it was something right a thing where it
was like not concrete and it was like
hey think about it you know like if you
want to do it
and then i think uh two or three months
later it became a bit more serious of
like
okay do you want to do it i think was
that similar thing to you yeah yeah
exactly
you know i think we had time to think
about it and then seriously they asked
us
yeah and it went from the it went from a
hypothetical to oh
yeah oh this is actually happening i'm
i'm moving to japan
and this because yeah i don't think i've
spoke to you about
your thoughts on it i maybe i might have
at the time but i can't remember but
were you like
from the first time you got heard or you
were given the offer
were you gonna take it or yeah i think i
was i think i was always
going to take it i think because i had
wanted to move to japan for a while even
if it was
for a little bit yeah i hadn't really
put much thought into how long i wanted
to stay here but i was thinking
hey you're going to get this chance yes
once in your life i want to i want to
like if i hated it then i would great at
least at least i've done it right yeah
yeah
um but i was i was pretty concrete
when i got the offer yeah that you're
gonna take it i was gonna take it i was
what i was more worried about was how it
was actually
going to happen or how what the process
yeah i think there's a lot of stuff like
that where
i guess because we'd only interacted
with book walker through maylene yeah it
was
i think maybe we were a bit like
skeptical about what goes on in the back
end right
like i don't know what's happening right
yeah um but they're great by the way
uh the two characters very nice and
melee will kill me if i say i don't know
but it's against their contract um
but i think the huge like advantage for
at least youtube was the fact that and i
know a lot of people who don't do this
and
definitely should is that you guys
visited japan
enough times yeah to like yeah
well i mean i i was there for a while i
mean yeah but
like i know a lot of stories of like
people who move here
just like thinking like oh japan is this
like a wonderful place yeah you know
like nothing could go wrong and
everyone's so friendly and then they
move here
and their expectations are just
completely
rejected yeah there's a lot of stuff
that's different between
moving here and living visiting and
moving here which we can get into later
yeah because
for me i think it goes back to the
mentality of i never felt like moving
here or i never thought i would you know
want to move here
um because of the fact that i liked
anime you know i think i think that's
the biggest thing
if you want to move to japan just purely
for anime you're gonna have a basketball
play the weeaboo dream yeah it's like
it's it's not it's not real
like honestly there's probably worse
reasons but it's pretty what
like for me in terms of my exposure to
anime it hasn't actually increased too
much
compared to when i was living in
thailand because there is like a massive
anime fandom in thailand and just like
asia in general
yeah so unlike like there was there's a
big difference between like
like say england to japan but from
thailand to japan i still have to watch
anime online sub because i can't watch
you can't watch it on tv because i don't
understand
it yet even if you did the schedule of
airing is so
yeah i'm not going to stay up till 3am
like it's just not worth it exactly it
kind of reminds me like old cartoon
broadcast schedule right like yeah it's
just all over the place
constantly like it's weird yeah anyway i
think when i was presented with the
offer i
didn't initially i wasn't that keen on
it mainly because i
i didn't really know anything and i i
you know when someone's like hey you
want to come here
to this country it's like okay i mean
japan's cool but i literally
don't yeah i literally don't know
anything yeah um
i think over time i just especially when
i found out that you were gonna go 100
i think that was like all right well at
least i have you know my boys here
so if i do get lonely i'll be good yeah
um
but i mean you know meeting friends
wasn't a problem anyway but
i think it is scary though it is part of
it yeah i think that
i'll go into later with like what i
think is important yeah you move here
and then just got to the point where i
had nothing better going on and people
gave me so much [ __ ] for saying that in
my video by the way i got oh really yeah
i literally said in my video i said uh i
said nothing better going on that's why
i moved here and people think that like
i'm being like nonchalant or joking like
i didn't like when you're a youtuber you
don't have anything to do
other than youtube and hang out with
your friends and do whatever you need to
do to be happy but yeah
i literally had nothing better going on
so i'm like in my head
there's no reason why i wouldn't take
this because it gives me a purpose to
you know just better myself as a person
i get to learn new things get to meet
new people i mean that's a huge reason
why i moved as well is because like in
australia
like you know what are you doing right
it's like like you know
i had like great friends you know from
uni
and high school who i would hang out
with every now and then right yeah and
like
you know i had places to go to yeah but
it wasn't
exciting anymore for me like it was just
routine yeah and like totally i hate
getting into a routine with
anything right so i was like yeah i mean
you know i haven't like yes i've spent
half my life here
technically but i haven't really like
gone out to like fully support the
country and even
four years later i'm nowhere near close
to exploring this place yeah like there
are so many more places i want to go to
i still haven't left tokyo it's been
like eight months like i haven't left
tokyo
that road trip that we planned all right
once once the roanoke is gone it's
happening okay
i've i've left tokyo once yeah
the the decision to move to japan
funnily enough was probably the easiest
part of the process
really oh yeah okay well first of all i
mean you're very lucky
yeah you know if if you're half japanese
and have a japanese passport
it's gonna be easy to move here
for anyone else who's thinking about
moving to japan
uh whatever visa you're thinking about
coming on
it is going to be a tower yeah it's it's
and this year
or this year from oh sorry from april uh
this year i believe they changed the
rules to make
visas more uh easy or easier to get
because
they need more immigrants to work here
because the population's getting older
right
and they allocated 40 000 worker permits
and in the article
they only managed to allocate 4 000 this
year of the 40 000. what
of the yeah wait it's 40 000 like per
year uh
for some specific kind of uh like visa
for this year
right right they only managed to do one
tenth of that
which is like not a problem because i
don't think there's like and
like there's not demand to move here
yeah probably one of the countries that
i think people have most interested in
moving to out of a lot of places right
yeah
and it's just i think that that if
anything says a lot about how
difficult it is to move here yeah
exactly i mean i can't speak on any
other visa processes but
you know everyone i've talked to has had
like a difficult process unless you're
just coming here for a tourist visa
super easy it's super easy
or if you're one of those countries that
has working holiday visas yeah which
unfortunately uh america does not
so sorry like like if you want advice on
how to move here easily get a working
holiday visa yeah it's
probably gonna be i think those last uh
maybe like a year and a half
yeah year and a half i think it depends
on the country at least australians have
a year and a half wow right i don't know
about you
maybe uk has like six months to a year
maybe
depends but yeah a lot of paperwork it
fell out yeah
i think the hardest part of the process
was finding an apartment oh my god oh my
god
i mean i'm a japanese citizen and it was
still a pain in the ass
you hear about on youtube and twitter
and everything like it's hard it's hard
and then you see some people saying like
yeah it's
people are exaggerating it is it is 100
percent
[ __ ] difficult especially if you're a
foreigner as well uh
you basically play under different rules
yeah it's sad to say like i
i you know in the uk i think if you have
money you get an apartment i think more
importantly especially if you're a
youtuber
oh my god oh what because the the the
hardest thing
at least in japan from my experience
about why it's so hard to get
a [ __ ] apartment here is because
freelancing is not a job here yeah
freelancing you might as well be
unemployed according to this
government's like
the government's like that typical asian
parent yeah it's like what you're not a
doctor or an engineer or a lawyer
it's like you're out of here you're
unemployed right yeah you're working
part-time
and that's due to because they're
worried about if you can pay all the
rent and what
yeah right but the thing is is that they
don't even like
you know at least in like i don't know
about the uk or thailand but at least in
australia
you when you sign up for like an
apartment right usually the landlord
will be like okay can i see your bank
account
yeah like just to see how much money you
have saved up you know regardless of
what job you do
we just want to see that you have you
know money in the bank and if you do
then you're like okay
but here in japan they don't check your
bank they check
your work status to make sure that
there's like a constant flow of money
coming yeah
and it's not just that as well because
if you're not japanese
and especially if you can't speak
japanese most places aren't even going
to talk to you or consider you because
that was a big problem we had
because we went through like an agency
and we just
made a list of about 10 to 20 apartments
that we were interested in um and we
sent it off and applied
for reject rejected from all of them
jesus christ and we had a company as a
guarantor
yeah like having the like payments
secured wasn't the issue it was like
a lot of the time it was really dumb
stuff like yeah can you sort the bins
properly and like stuff like that
yes we're not 12 year old it's like it's
like the main concern you'll hear all
the time is can you sort your trash
properly and it's like okay it might be
different from where i'm from but like
i can learn yeah it's like like the the
government councils in the area give you
an english manual that tells you how to
do it like it is tedious and it is a lot
more complex in most places but
it's not like it's not rocket science
yeah it's not like you're having to do
like the weirdest stuff imaginable to
this stuff like it's basically just
rinse your stuff separate all of it
that's pretty much it
and i know there's some places uh in in
europe that do way more thorough that
probably don't have this concern when
they're
letting people yeah right houses it's
just like because it's the least of your
concerns it's
you know yeah it's ridiculous yeah and
the thing is
that if you'd go through an agency for
example that specializes in foreigners
and people who can't speak japanese
you're going to be paying so much for
that ability to pay like a premium
for that bill and that rent so it's
you you either have a [ __ ] difficult
time finding a place
and getting past all the barriers or
you're just gonna pay a [ __ ] ton of
money
and those aren't two very good options
the the only concern that they often
cite like building managers etc
that i find is like somewhat all right
that's fair enough is that they're
worried that you'll run away
yeah but run away and not pay the rent
but if you have a guarantor
that's the whole [ __ ] point of that
problem which you can't run away you
if we run away you're still getting your
money like yeah and the house is vacant
great no damage to it like this is a
win-win for the company i don't
understand like we do
you play by their rules it's because
it's just like typical
like this is like one aspect of like
japanese
it's definitely one of the worst culture
that i learned very quickly it's that
like
it doesn't matter what the business is
if they're not
100 million sure that this is going to
go through
yeah it might as well no risk they don't
do risk
in any business venture whether that be
paying for rent or like
anything it's like if they're not 100
million
sure in every possible avenue ever yeah
it's just not happening and
you know you know that's ridiculous i
think that'd be interesting to talk
about later on when we get to more of
like the stuff that we've
experienced here yeah um but like was
there any part of the visa process
applying for i'm sure people are
wondering i got a lot of emails i'm sure
you did as well
people asking hey how did you get a visa
like was it hard
etc etc yeah if there's any advice you
can give someone who's watching who
wants to come japan what would you say
is like the main piece of advice
if they want to get a working visa um i
mean i didn't apply for a working visa
yeah but uh so i don't have too much
experience we didn't apply for it we had
immigration lawyers help us yeah we had
immigration lawyers help us but
i mean i've applied for visas before and
yeah the worst the most painful part is
just waiting
it's it's you're gonna be waiting a lot
you're gonna be waiting a long time and
you're just gonna be in this limbo
limbo kind of because we had what it was
like the initial thing where they filed
for something called a certificate of
eligibility
which is basically if the government
decides if you can have a visa
which isn't the visa itself which
already sounds to me like that sounds
like we're adding steps
where steps don't need to be but as you
move to japan you'll learn that's what
they love to do
so yeah we had to wait what was it six
weeks for that six to eight weeks yeah
it could have been six to eight weeks
for this piece of paper to arrive which
then they send by post which
makes you feel so uneasy because you're
like they're sending me a piece of paper
through the mail
that i've waited two months for and
you're just like something's gonna go
wrong
someone's gonna take it so you get you
get this piece of paper right um
to get this this thing you need to prove
that you have a good reason to work in
japan that you're the job or
you know because you have to say what
your work is yeah they need to check
that you
are actually like in that field et
cetera et cetera we had to
send so much evidence yeah that
we were we were doing valuable work that
could
which i'm sure some people would argue
youtube isn't but you know
yeah at the end of the day if we bring
in money to the government and pay taxes
it's valuable work right yeah but yeah
basically just
how many companies we've worked with
what's work
that's notable that you know that that
and then why we need to be in japan
what it felt like was i was applying for
a job yeah yeah you know
it was like here's here's all my
achievements here's what i can bring for
your country
please please let me play on your team
coach
and then yeah so we get that certificate
of eligibility yeah which
is we get that and then you have to go
to the
embassy so you turn that into a visa and
then they'll put uh
yeah again there's more steps because
first of all if you live in the uk
uh the only embassy is in london now i
felt i would feel bad for someone who
lives in like in the north of scotland
i don't think they have an embassy in
scotland no no and in wales i had to go
all the way from wales that i mean
luckily this
fast train doesn't matter yeah point is
one embassy so you're going to be taking
a day trip to get this thing
yeah worst part is is that then if you
go to the embassy which you might have
have to have traveled cross-country for
you have to wait five days
to then actually get the visa which is a
little thing that is print out and
staple in your passport so you have to
go back
the embassy you have to go back right so
i i just went home because i'm like i'm
not staying in london for five days yeah
like if you're if you're poor you know
you haven't got much money and you can't
you know the train tickets in the uk are
expensive right like
there's a lot of things where it's just
like my god why are we doing this but
then again like realistically how many
people in like the [ __ ] middle of
scotland is going i'm sure there's
i'm sure i bet there's one person from
like like the north island and like
scotland is like dude i had to fly
[ __ ] that [ __ ] if you want that one
person watching subscribe
and and to make matters even more um
stressful you lost your past ideas
this motherf we were meeting up at the
embassy to collect our visas yeah
and this [ __ ] lost my
perspective i just heard that story
i couldn't [ __ ] believe oh my god
that was like one of the worst days like
you can't
write that [ __ ] it was like it was
horrible all because you didn't have a
[ __ ] backpack
i i carry my passport in my jeans pocket
which i'm hearing people
like oh my god
i'm like cringing hearing that man i'm
like so okay i've traveled like
all over the world just having my my
passport in my okay i have lost it
before and you guys know i have
i lost it in america as well i found it
though luckily but anyway so i was going
to the train station to pick up
you know go to the train go to london
yeah and as my train arrived
i'm like i always tap my pockets right
to make sure it's there i tap my pockets
it's it's not in there it's not in there
and
i'm like [ __ ] and what's running through
my head is like
all of this like months of work i feel
bad for the company they paid for
lawyers like
all these people who have like banked on
me coming and i've put
so much work into this myself and other
people yeah also having a mental
breakdown i don't think i've ever like
had that much of a like
quick mental breakdown in my life yeah
and
it's to be expected and it was like
gradually getting worse and like the
hour i couldn't find it
yeah i scoured this train station a tiny
train station in wales it's called like
flint it's you can look it up on
it's literally just like a platform
right there's nowhere this should have
gone where i couldn't have found it
right
could not find it check my car quickly
drove home to find it didn't find it
came back to check again
couldn't find it going to the police
station literally everything i could not
find you have no idea
what happened i have no idea what have
my passport and then eventually it was
getting like
3 4 p.m and i was like okay i'm gonna
just call up the
the british government and tell them hey
can you cancel my passport i want to
apply for another one
and that whole thing was an ordeal and
then my main concern was like all right
well i lost my passport
do i have to restart the whole visa
process again yeah luckily the embassy
were like no as long as you have like
the
certificate which i didn't lose great i
could
redo it so i had to scramble to get a
new passport and that was the whole
thing and i got one within like five
days luckily and
luckily it all went well but like it was
just so stressful
on top of like already the stress that i
was already at my limit with stress
that whole period because of this whole
thing yeah and that was just like the
full like i had a full breakdown that
day that was horrible and i think i like
joked about it on twitter but like i was
like not okay that day
oh no no no and the worst part is right
it's when you [ __ ] up this badly
you can accept that you [ __ ] up but
it's it's messaging your friends being
like
hey i'm not gonna be in london in like
in like two hours they're like oh
why what's up i'm like i lost my
passport
no because i remember reading that text
because i was waiting for you outside
the embassy
when uh when when you're like uh i get a
message from connor being like i'm gonna
be a bit like 30 minutes late little did
i know i was like oh all right all right
i'll get a coffee and i i i see the
event unfold as he's just texting me
so he goes yeah i i can't find my
passport i'm just gonna
go uh look for it quickly and then it
just
and it's just you like just breaking
down
every message and it just ends with
yeah i don't i don't think i can come
and i'm still annoyed to this day
because i went around this is a very
small town where i lost it i went around
like every shop in that area
i had literally everyone in that area
hey if you find this passport
can you call me right away because if
not i'm gonna just cancel it today
i still never heard anything yeah i like
i was crazy and i
don't know how i lost it so like from
your experience yeah to
for anyone who's listening if there's
anything that you need to know to make
the process
easier what would you guys say get a
degree yeah degree helps a lot
especially if it's you know like not an
associates like like like a bachelor's
degree
yeah i think a lot of their forms didn't
recognize associates i think it actually
said like specified like but
i think associates is a thing in japan
it's not a thing in the uk i don't think
yeah it's not the same
in japan right i mean it is a thing but
like it's not like
yeah yeah as heavily emphasized on as a
bachelor's degree
yeah i and i i saw a lot of people
asking like oh how did we get it etc
like you you need to like have
especially with a country this strict
you need to have like concrete proof
that like you can do something here like
you can't just come here on a whim
that you're worth unless unless you're
like extremely extremely rich and they
want your tax money like i think that
the only other reason like you need
something like
even then you need a degree yeah yeah
they'll find a way to because
they'll be like where are you getting
this money from yeah and i imagine just
having like
a a fair amount of experience in what
you're doing and the reason you're
coming here will help you
uh i mean i can't talk about most just
what we went through or basically just
come here to teach english
that is like the instant like get in
button yeah pretty much
i can speak english and i can teach it
to someone they feel like
it's probably like not a bad way to if
you if your goal ultimately is
living in japan forever it's probably
not a bad way to like transition into
living here
because i know i know a lot of friends
personally who did start
with teaching english and then gradually
moved on to something else cause like
you can gain
by teaching english english you can gain
connections in the country yeah and then
maybe
that transitions to an like a normal
office job or something like that
working with the company you know but if
you just want to get your foot through
the door i'm teaching english would be
the easiest way
for anyone to be able to do it but you
still need a degree
yeah either way you need a degree but
they pretty much accept everyone on that
as far as i'm aware
again if you have a degree yeah it
doesn't matter how good your high school
essays were if you don't have a degree
in in that like yeah which is why i'm so
glad to drop out of university
listen to your asian parents go to uni
if you want to go to youtube
degrees right yeah yeah okay engineering
baby let's go oh really yeah engineering
i never actually have known what you're
you have an engineering degree i haven't
yeah he has electrical engineering i
have mechanical engineering
oh wow but he's a masters i have a
bachelor's i've got a [ __ ] masters
model
look at this boy spending more than four
years at uni
i i got to the third year i was like i
can't do it anymore i can't i can't do
this yeah i was like
have i got the required minimum yeah get
me out of here
i don't want to be here for another year
dude so like now that you guys moved to
japan
what would you say are the pros and cons
of actually living here
i mean i want i want to know from you
guys right because i mean i've
experienced
japan pretty much for half my life so
i'm not like
to me the pros and cons are just very
natural to me and i feel like you
the most of the cons that we might me
and god might have
you won't ever experience because one
you can speak the language and read it
fluently
yeah and i don't know man there's some
though that's the face of a foreign
like i'm just gonna say it there's a lot
of discrimination here
but i mean what country does i would say
i like understand it more because
growing up
in and like in an asian country there's
definitely discrimination in asia
it's just very different from what you
see in the west i think
that's the thing it's not racism it's
it's more xenophobia yeah yeah right and
if you guys don't know the difference
between that
like racism is where it's like oh you're
a different race to me
yeah so therefore you are worse than me
and xenophobia is like oh you're not
from
here yeah therefore you're i think he
comes because
i think it comes more from a place of
ignorance
because it's just you know because you
guys didn't open the country
i mean japan has been a closed island
for like the past two thousand exactly
right so
what do you expect exactly um so it it
like it makes sense to me um but like
for example finding finding an apartment
that was my first experience
with that where if you didn't if you
want if you're not japanese and
if you didn't speak japanese then they
were very
like scared to even touch you you know
consider you or even like or in that
case
especially when you have a company
backing you in my mind i was like i
don't see what the problem is here like
i'm like
i'm like the model tenant here i'm
single i don't know
we can't write your name in kanji yeah
right that's the problem
katakana name ew gross but i mean i have
that problem too because like
even though i am japanese and you have a
japanese name
yeah the fact that i don't look it is
already a huge like wall that
yeah regular japanese people find a
difficulty in getting over because like
it's really funny as well because like
during my intern days as well like i had
to be like the guy to like if there was
like a business partner coming to the
office
i had to be the one to like get on the
phone with them and being like okay
we're gonna you guys are coming at this
time in this day okay i'll come down
to like meet you guys and greet you up
to the office yeah but when i speak
japanese i don't have an accent
and my name is japanese so there were so
many times where i would go down to
greet them
and they'd be like who the [ __ ]
are you the you're not the person on the
phone ryan i was like yeah
i am it's like oh oh we thought you were
japanese and i'm like
i am japanese and they're like and
it's just so so many of like the older
generation especially they just
can't fathom that there are these things
called
hafuz yeah it's just not a thing it's
like you're either japanese or you're
not japanese
yeah yeah because the way i treat is
treat it is that
i i treat it like exactly the same how i
would treat
my grandmother or like my grand my
grandad who
lived in thailand in this in the small
village their entire [ __ ] life knew
nothing about the
outside world so they just they just
didn't know
you know yeah it's the same way with a
lot of japanese people where
some of them especially like older
people have never interacted with a
foreigner or
or even like got to know them or even
knows what's what the outside world is
like beyond what they see on the news
and what they see on tv you know what i
mean
and you don't want to like import
anything from japanese tv
no no like you don't oh my god some of
the stuff they are it's like we're
called trash taste podcasts like if
there's anything trashier than trash
taste podcast
it is [ __ ] japanese tv it is full of
absolute
garbage yeah it's it's something i wish
that like a lot of youtubers
whose channel is focused all about japan
would like
look speak about a little more because
it's not like something you can ignore
like
if you're if you're foreign and or even
look foreign and live here
you're gonna experience it like totally
yeah and
i i didn't know anything about this
because no youtubers talk about it or
anything yeah i feel like it's such an
important
like topic especially when you talk
about living in japan
it's gonna be a factor like you're gonna
be stared at and it's not
like like you've said like it's it's not
a place of like hatred or anything it's
just like
they don't see those kind of people a
lot of problem with a lot of like j
vloggers that do cover topics like that
because i
like when you live here you pretty much
get to know every j vlogger
yeah natural it's such a small community
so i know pretty much
every like notable job you hear and
there's been a number of them that i
know that have made topics on like
the blatant xenophobia here in japan
yeah yeah but the problem is
i think a lot of those videos aren't
taken seriously by the internet because
it's seen as like a privileged problem
yeah yeah it's like you get to live in
japan you know so therefore
you should just be able to put up with
this [ __ ] right because you get to
experience all this other cool stuff
when
you know that's not the point of the
video right like it's still a problem
regardless of how privileged you may
seem
living here like i think the worst thing
that happened to me was um
the time one time we got the police
called on us
oh yeah and uh explain why we got the
police call
we didn't do anything illegal we just
played mario party really loud yeah
at like two in the morning very drunk
that's that that was all bad you know we
caught we can't really complain about
that okay
so basically we got a noise complaint um
so the policeman came
and he basically asked joey you know um
who
who is he with yeah and i remember you
you saying like oh there's
you know one american one you know
british person and then there's
me who who i'm thai so he mentioned that
i'm i'm with a thai friend
and as soon as he mentioned that he was
with a thai friend the police was the
policeman was like oh
can we see your thai friend can we see
your thai friend
i go up there and i start getting
grilled
about why i'm here they want to see my
passport and everything and they're
asking me about my my visa
but you show them your british party no
no as soon as i
as soon i was like oh i have a british
passport though they were like
okay you're free to go
it was so messed up and i was like oh
what the [ __ ] just happened what was
that it was so messed up like
and and the fact that they like only
called you yeah yeah
up there even though there was like a it
was like the most
multi-like cultural room in probably the
entire apartment building i'm gonna say
it now i wasn't making the noise
you weren't like the quietest one there
if anything and it's just i
like that was the first time i like ever
experienced that too and i'm just like
jesus christ like they can't even be
like
subtle about no no no yeah and i'm like
you do know
like this is like not cool right like
but to them it's just yeah you know i
think you just
i don't know i know i get stared out a
lot which is weird for me because
obviously coming from like the widest
place on earth i was just like another
you know just another like person and
yeah i would've never experienced this
in my life
yeah um which i guess is also strange
and also
like um this goes
but okay in japan not exactly known for
the best like legal system if you will
okay
normally if you're like arrested or
whatever or convicted
uh charged with a crime you normally get
like it's like a 98 99 conviction
i don't know where this is going right
but also like this is the first time
i've ever been like around police where
i'm like [ __ ] please don't stop
me please don't stop like i
i guess this is like conor checking his
white privilege for the first time ever
but like
because i if the police stop me right i
can't explain to them
why i might like i don't know what i
might do that's wrong you know what i
mean
i don't want to get [ __ ] arrested
because like i get myself out of that
hole
right and yeah it's just a weird
experience for me that i've never felt
before and i'm sure people are like wow
connor
really seeing his white privilege for
the first time ever in his life
but it's weird it's weird though right
because that's like stuff that i never
considered i have to like
worry about ever right you have to like
kind of experience it
unfortunately like first hand to like
really understand it right and that's
the problem is that there are so many
like
i guess you know controversial topics
like that concerning being a foreigner
living in japan that
i'm sure a lot of jvloggers want to talk
about but because
from the position that they're talking
about it from it's very difficult to
make it
bring it up like oh they hate chinese
people right because because it's like
it's also like for someone who's the for
a foreigner who's never lived in japan
yeah it's very hard to like
swallow and understand being like no
that doesn't happen right
that must be just you whereas it's it's
very much a
common occurrence for any like foreigner
who lives here unfortunately
it's it's unfortunate but it's it's just
a thing where you move here and you
realize there's pretty quickly yeah
pretty quickly yeah it's you know it
works differently and people view you
differently
as well um but i think to me that is you
know
the worst experience i've had yeah about
moving to japan apart from
okay can we talk about how slow japanese
businesses work
yeah my
[ __ ] god everyone has this image that
japan's this
like super optimized place like the most
optimized system on earth they figured
it out speed running business
like things just work you go to a
restaurant you press a button on a
tablet
and the food just appears in front of
you you know you're like this is the
future
and then you and then you go to a
japanese business and you're like oh
is that is that a fax machine are you
using a fax machine right now
or just like stuff you never even
considered like a problem or like yeah
asking for permission for like the the
slightest thing on earth like it's just
like
you show a logo or something in a video
we gotta find permission to do that it's
like yeah
just [ __ ] upload it it's a problem
they'll tell us you know see but like
that's the thing right is that
japan doesn't understand what well
no risk as well but at least with like
what we do
business-wise japan doesn't have fair
use
no yeah so it's so difficult to get
permission for any like if you ask like
like as you said it's like can
can i just show this logo of your
company that is like
publicly available to anybody yeah just
like slap it on for like
two seconds i'm not even gonna like
mention your name just slap it on it has
to go through like a hundred layers of
the company
just to get a simple yes and that could
take like a couple of days if you're
lucky
yeah usually a week to maybe a month
yeah and it's like
it's a business model where there's like
imagine if every employer was a boss and
everyone had to ask for permission
constantly it's like you employees can't
make their own decisions they have to
ask
their boss who then asks their boss and
that takes a week
and that's just to see if you can
sharpen your pencil right like we
haven't even got to business yet like
we're just trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] happening it's not even just
business it's just
stunning everything it's everything
everything moves so slowly
like i remember when you sign up for a
gym membership oh my god
it took us how an hour hour and a half
an hour and a half to sign up for a
[ __ ] to get a gym car
right because you know you know in um
you know in america or
like basically everywhere where you get
you get the terms and conditions right
[ __ ] scroll through you click accept
no in japan you're gonna
sit there and you're gonna read every
[ __ ] term and you can agree to every
[ __ ] term individually
and they're gonna they're gonna sit
there with you to make sure you read it
yeah you not only are subject to going
through the fine
print which is no longer fine it's just
print
like but they're like let me read it out
for you
in case you're a [ __ ] illiterate
piece of [ __ ] it's like see that's why
like when i signed up for the gym
membership because it's all written in
japanese right
i straight up just said like i can read
it
i saved myself like an hour of pain i'm
just like
listening to this like [ __ ] hour-long
monologue from this like
yeah i think that's because we were
foreign he was like he he really
really wanted to make sure he understood
and bear in mind these weren't terms
like conditions that were like any like
social things it was like literally
the the bare bones of what a gym needs
to make sure you know like right yeah
like you know don't run on the treadmill
if you know your legs don't work right
like
just stuff like don't basically don't
sue us stuff right stuff you wouldn't
take for granted i remember he was like
asking us
our translator like if we understood
every single point every one of them is
like
do you understand that on the treadmill
you have to have your hands on the
treadmill at all times
and i looked at like like our friend
abby i was like is he serious
like it's not a joke right he wants me
to like like he legally has to
i have to agree that i'm gonna put my
hands on have you ever seen
like anyone butter like a crippled old
man right on the treadmill
oh yes because that's how i run like
three hands
no one does that and you literally like
you're signing this agreement and you
turn your head to see
ten people on the treadmill none of them
holding their hands and you're like
yes i agree and it's just
it's all [ __ ] that's all you do and
and this is the stuff that you never
experience as a tourist because yeah
it's like perfectly separated the stuff
that you experience as a tourist
yeah to like the stuff you experience
living here and the moment you do
something
that is remotely permanent or
reoccurring in a contract you you better
be ready to
bring every document that you've ever
had in your life
and the hanko which you'll lose a lot
i'm surprised they didn't ask for like a
[ __ ] birth certificate when signing
up for the gym because
it's so formal with everything it's like
who
you don't need to know my life story
that's the perfect word everything in
japan is so
formal and you don't see it as a tourist
because everything when you're in japan
on tourism
and you're just sightseeing everything
just works right you go to a restaurant
it just works
living here all the little intricacies
and all the little
things you take for granted that should
be quick yeah just takes a million
processors when
it's just the most unoptimized thing in
the world yeah
um and there's just like a lot of things
that don't make sense like
in contracts like i've going back to
paying rent
there's this thing called a key fee what
was it like
what's this it's like it's key money
right
money more money and and i mean you can
explain it if you want go ahead
okay what can i explain it's two months
of rent some
sometimes it's so the amount is about
two months of rent
that you pay to the rent owner to say
thank you for renting me your place for
free like
you don't get any you don't get it back
you you this money is literally not a
deposit
you just pay two months of rent just
which you also have to pay a deposit
yeah and then on top of the deposit that
you have to pay
just it's basically a dick sucking thing
like that's what it is it's like thank
you so much for letting me stay in your
apartment that's what it is
and then it doesn't end there because
you then have to pay the rental
the the agency that got you the house
you have to pay a month's rent to them
as a fee
which is just stupid because i think in
every other country they take their
split
from the person renting the house right
like not from you because
renting a house shouldn't be you
shouldn't have to pay like six to eight
months
up front that's ridiculous yeah and it's
i think it's the reason why
uh a lot of homeless people here also
struggle to get houses because how the
[ __ ] are you gonna get six months worth
of rent right good money are you
kidding me like that's like you expect
when you when you look at the rent you
expect like okay this is how much i'm
going to pay for the first time
yeah you're paying like me two months
yeah maybe like a month or two
yeah yeah but like no it's like double
or triple that and i'm just like
jesus christ like it's ridiculous yeah
stupid
it's it's like yes six months worth of
rent yeah in one sitting and you're not
gonna get like
two months of that back at all because
they want you to stay in that apartment
they don't want you to leave
yeah and i i like i like going around i
like moving getting a new place seeing
how things are
knowing what i like you don't like but
now it's pretty much just solidified
that i'm not leaving this because i'm
gonna charge out the ass if i want to
move
because it's like a minimum of like two
years to like stay in one place two
years yeah and even then if you're
moving like the amount like
that you paid in that first month that
that if you split that across two years
of rent yeah you'd be
way overpriced oh yeah i think that's
why
like i that's that's one thing right
about like uh
living in japan that i've i've
personally never understood for the
longest time but i think finally now i
i do understand is when people say like
man japan is such an expensive place
but like when you think about it it's
like no it's
like because you know when when i think
oh japan is such an expensive place i
think like getting out eating out
like drinking and i'm like no it's
relatively cheap but then you think
about
all the bills six months worth of rent
in the first month kind of [ __ ] i'm
like okay
maybe yeah it is a little bit ridiculous
and expensive
yeah i mean you can live frugally here
it's uh it's not too hard to live
through
yeah you can live cheap it's it's like
not a problem i mean convinies you can
live offline yeah oh my god
we can do a whole episode that's
basically the best thing about japan
right
no matter where you are you are in with
like a hundred meter radius of
everything you need
like no questions japan is the only
country where
the word convenience store actually
lives up to its name
yeah yeah because it is actually one of
the most convenient places that you
could
god i love kombini so [ __ ] much man
like
not even the food the food's amazing
like you expect this like if you go to a
gas station in any country in the world
yeah and you try and convince me to buy
something that's been cooked
in that building yeah i would rather
like just get salmonella like i'm not
gonna risk you
just seeing what they give me you know
what i mean like yeah those nasty hot
dogs that have been on rotation for like
20 hours
at least but the one thing that like i
thought was just like the most
genius thing that japan does which i do
not understand why every other country
doesn't do this
is the fact they just have like a
printing machine in there
so no one needs to buy a printer or
buying you can just go to this place
that's probably within like
you know 100 meters of you 200 meters at
most max yeah
you pay like 10 cents or whatever and
you can get a printed a4 copy of
whatever you want
because no one needs to print that much
[ __ ] right no i've never needed to print
more than like
one document expensive right and it
dries
as well so you might print one thing
it's gone dry yeah and i feel so bad for
admitting that i've done this but in the
uk uh and university
when we had to have a printer i was
printing a lot of documents i used to
like
the ink was more expensive to buy on its
own than just buying a new printer
yeah every time i ran out of ink i
bought a new
serious printer that's like 200 iq move
though
because bear in mind right this is the
time when you're university right where
you're losing 20 pounds which is like
like 30 bucks at the time it was like a
big deal right like i don't
you don't get any money i can't afford
to lose 30 bucks that's like 10 instant
ramens dude
that's like like like two nights out
yeah if i'm good
so i would go to like the charity shop
uh and just like give it to them and
every single like month on cue i'd come
in with a printer and just the exact
same
amazon basics printer and give it and i
just thought like i can appreciate this
so much now that
in japan if you want to print anything
you don't have to buy a printer you
don't have to [ __ ] around worrying about
which ink cartridge mats with your
printer yeah you go to the convenience
store and you print it off and it's just
like
it makes sense and the best thing is is
that like you know if you do need to
like print out like a document or
anything you can just be like oh i can
do that but you know i can also buy like
a drink
yeah yeah i can stock up my fridge yeah
it's all there
i can pay my bills you can pay your
bills
you can pay your bills at the
convenience store yeah that's wild to me
i don't anymore because that just takes
time but i did it you just did directly
it was a novelty
yeah because i think the best and worst
part of japan to me
is that it's like a dichotomy it either
works exceedingly well
too well exceedingly optimized always
just a hundred processors to do the
simplest [ __ ]
there's no middle ground nothing here
works okay yeah it either works
exceedingly well or it just doesn't work
at
all i think it's normally like
a public demand right convenience stores
trains everyone is using them
24 7. we want this easy as possible
all that it all works flawlessly yeah i
think where it comes into play
mostly is with like government agencies
like big companies that have
higher ups that don't want to change
things very fastly yeah and if you
thought like companies in the west don't
want to change things
my god you are in for like a surprise
most japanese companies haven't changed
since like the 70s because because not
only do they not want to change things
even if the person before them dies
they're like well they didn't want to
change it and i
really don't want to like you know step
on their toes even though they don't
exist anymore you know it's like
we've got to keep everything the same
way it was that's been working the
problem though is that japan has such a
double-edged sword
in terms of like maintaining culture
yeah it works
because it's maintaining tradition it's
very traditional in a lot of ways like
man look look i'm looking at japanese
web design
oh my god oh my god man i
i take it for granted how good we had it
like i didn't realize that i cared about
users i
i i when i was interning i was in the
web division department because that's
what i measured in at uni right so i had
to like
go around fixing basically like clients
like old websites
yeah and like anybody who like ever did
anything like html or css related can
relate to this but like
i almost had a stroke when i looked at
the source code and i saw a table
and i'm like that's something we haven't
used since like the early 90s like not
this is like early 90s type of web
design and they're
still using it today yeah yeah i don't
think i've seen
a single animation on a web page in
japan no
no like there's no graphics at all it's
it literally looks like
the first like windows iteration like
it's just it just looks so
[ __ ] cluttered weirdly enough the
best web design i have seen
is like landing pages for new anime yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah that's it that's the
thing
yeah good websites that i've seen i'm
like damn
these javascript for this [ __ ] jesus
before we move on to the logistics
i want to talk about staying to the car
to thank the pros
how good the [ __ ] food is oh my god
moving
moving here from england oh my god where
good food is you either it's you you
either have to pay a lot
or you have to cook it yourself it's
every everything here
tastes good it's it's it's just true
right everything
you never have a bad experience in japan
with food i swear to god that's like the
difference that i tell my parents the
most i'm like
in in the uk i don't know about
australia but when you go to the
restaurant
it's not a gamble it's but it kind of is
it's like you don't know if it's going
to be
okay or amazing and it's always a coin
flip you just don't know and you have to
go to find out
oh no that's 100 how it works in
australia right because there might be a
restaurant owned by a guy who has no
idea
what he's doing doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the food but in japan it is like
guaranteed no matter where you go you
will get good food yeah
yeah you are like never like you never
overcharged
either like you always pay a fair amount
and when you are overcharged
it is like the the taste and experience
is worth
exactly exactly i remember saying very
harsh words to my mom when she used to
just
you know i'm like how dare you give me
these this bland food all my life
when this stuff existed how many times
must i have beans and toast mother how
many times
can a man eat beans and toast i actually
still like it like when like when the
combini food here is better than
a lot of the restaurant food you can
find in british restaurants i
go to yeah i'm like man there's
something wrong with me there's
something wrong here man so that's the
insane thing is that i
i don't know if it's i don't know if
japan's the only country that's like
this but
it's cheaper to eat out than it is to
cook your own food it's the same thing
in thailand i think
because at least in australia like jesus
christ
no one goes to restaurants because it's
like i don't want to gamble
if this 25 pasta is going to be good or
not like i'm sorry i'm like i'm not that
rich
i'd rather just go to a supermarket and
just cook a five dollar pasta i'm here
in japan and to get like a single lime
a single lime i paid two dollars
yeah two dollars for a single [ __ ]
life
what the something i wish no i don't
think anyone's mentioned that on youtube
people don't tell you
how expensive it is to cook here yeah
yeah i don't know if this is just like
maybe in america it's different no we're
not from america and i know the prices
for fresh food in america is like
ridiculous yeah but in the uk i don't
know about australia
in the uk like buying ingredients is
so incredibly cheap nobody
eating out is not so much you do it for
the food it's more of like an experience
with your friends
no no it's for an event right it's a
luxury yeah don't do it because like
you know you you have the money it's
like you do it for a reason and
you like if you speak to someone in the
uk and i know that if you say like you
eat out every day in the uk everyone's
like what
the [ __ ] wrong yeah because like in
the uk you don't eat out alone yeah
right
it's very rare to do something like
eating out alone in here
more people eat out alone than cook yeah
then cook
you know because it's just more
convenient and it's cheaper as well
because my god vegetables here meats are
okay but vegetables are so expensive and
i don't know why
like and the biggest offender in my mind
lime's terrible peppers you know like
normal bell peppers
yeah in the uk i distinctly remember in
like aldi or even like tesco
it's like one pound 29 right for a pack
of three bell peppers right
that's like what 1.60 yeah in japan for
like a single bell pepper which comes
with its own packaging
it's like 180 yen so if you want to have
three bell peppers so that's that's two
bucks
six dollars for three bell pepper are
you [ __ ] good can we talk about the
biggest defender though which is fruits
oh my gosh roots
i like okay they're good they're good
they're good they're amazing
but jesus talk about overpriced yeah
like i know like
you know there are like japan has this
like weird obsession when it comes to
fruits where it's like
oh it's from this you've got a massage
oh it's from the specific prefecture
that specializes in that fruit therefore
if you want to buy an apple from like
aomori prefecture which is like known
for the apples it's like you know a
regular apple like
i don't know about the uk but at least
in australia it's like if you want like
a freshly ground
we don't [ __ ] know where apples come
from like good quality like you know
home-grown apple
right there like the most you'd pay is
maybe like a buck
yeah yeah i've never paid more than 50
cents for an apple no i don't know i
think i'd be shocked if i paid more than
whereas here if you want like a
specialized
branded apple which is like the only
kind of apples they have here for some
reason yes like
oh yeah 600 yen please there's no cheap
brands here it's right it's every
every brand has a certain story and it's
like that uh
it's like you know when you have asian
grandparents or something everything
they feed you has
health benefits or something yeah you
know
they they they feed you like this
vegetable or this fruit and they're like
oh this is really good for eggs this is
it's not proven but uh it's it's like a
wives tale right
the amount of like fat products they
sell here is like incredible
right like you know you'd think that
we're in the age of science right like
i thought that people like knew that
half the [ __ ] they see on packaging is
[ __ ] right yeah
like the amount of like uh just weight
loss
things that i've seen here is incredible
like put this pad on your belly and it
will just magically go because of the
gels and it's like
that's just not how the body works like
you know what's kind of incredible as
well like when it comes to like weight
loss like culture here in japan
apparently i saw somewhere and i don't
know don't quote me on this
but i saw a while ago that like japan is
really interesting when it comes to
weight loss because
we're one of the most healthiest
healthiest
countries in the world and yet i think
it's something ridiculous like one in
three people
diet it's crazy and i'm like you don't
need to diet because i and and that
whole
you know that whole thing comes from the
whole ridiculous standard of
everyone's here everybody needs to be
bulimic otherwise you're not considered
beautiful yeah
but like going back to the fruit thing i
i remember uh me and aki
went to like this new supermarket that
opened up near our place
yeah um and i wanted to check out the
fruit section because i'm always curious
i'm like
how can we get ripped off anymore um and
there was like this packet of uh
there were these cherries right i love
eating cherries there were these packet
of like cherries from america
yeah which were like there was like 30
of them in there and it was like 400 yen
i'm like okay a tad expensive but not
too
bad right next to there there was a pack
of another 30
cherries but they were from like ibaraki
or like somewhere local
and it was obviously some kind of brand
right guess how much these cherries were
just going off japan experience like 30
bucks
okay so like three thousand yen how much
do you think it was i think like 25
uh hundred yen it's like two thousand
yeah two thousand five hundred yen right
twenty five bucks yeah
think of uh six thousand five hundred
jesus
for thirty cherries homegrown
okay like what like
i saw like i was really tempted to buy
just being like i swear to god if one
cherry doesn't give me an orgasm like
it's it's not worth it yeah
yeah i know right it's not worth it it's
good it's good fruit don't get me wrong
yeah but is it worth the [ __ ] premium
that i'm paying right
i don't think so i don't think so like
like it's already
a luxury just to buy regular food yeah
yeah regular non-branded food exactly
it's like who is buying this that's
that's my biggest concern it's like
what kind of fruit elitist is like
buying these like
60 dollar cherries from like down the
road you know five-star michelin
[ __ ] cherries like what who is buying
these
and being like yes i can definitely
taste like the homegrown quality in this
it's the it's the [ __ ] elderly it's
the grandmaster this is hidden health
benefits
this is low gmo this cherry will fix
your erectile dysfunction
this isn't from america it's homegrown
going back to you know uh people who
stay thin in japan i think one
preconception i had is that i would just
move to japan and because oh god because
japanese food is so healthy
you just like lose weight automatically
i'd like
zero efforts lose weight automatically
most restaurants
have a menu surprise surprise and uh if
you just pick the unhealthy option you
read the unhealthy
yeah yeah you gain just as much weight i
think the whole preconception is that
like
i think especially when it comes from
like americans yeah yeah it's just it's
not so much about like
the actual fact that like the food is
healthier and i'm sure like if you
like constantly go eat out of like
traditional japanese restaurants that's
sort of traditional japanese
food yes you're probably getting
healthier stuff yeah but
i think it just seems healthier
especially when compared to like
americans because
the portion sizes are just smaller that
yeah and like the whole conbini all that
stuff is definitely not healthy oh no no
that's not enough
it's delicious but it's not it's ordered
that's the problem
everything's delicious so you just want
to keep eating more and more right right
i think we like we mistake it as like a
food culture thing as to why everyone's
so thin here but it's definitely like
when you live here you realize really
quickly it's a lifestyle thing yeah it's
definitely
because they walk so much most people do
exercise unless they're super busy with
work and
i mean that's already draining enough
but i've noticed that people don't
really like eat
lunch or breakfast much here it's like a
light bite most of the time unless it's
a business meal
yeah that's when they'll eat lunch but
most people i think just have like an
onigiri or like a small snack
like a calorie mate right and even then
i think most people are just too
exhausted by the time they finish work
they just have something just because
they need to
yeah and then they go to bed where i
mean when you're a youtuber like
i'm i i eat because i'm bored and trust
me there is more than enough stuff to
eat here that is like
terrible i'm sure the amount of food
they just like are used to eating as
well is greatly different to like any
like standard of like a westerner right
oh no like for me when i whenever i have
like a sweet like uh like an ice cream
everything is sweet here yeah everything
everything and it's so good like
normally i hate sweets but now but now
when i go to a company i have to get at
least one
snack or one suite but like the one
thing i can't forgive
especially this is not just japan this
is all asian countries yes
sweet bread oh i i just think they
i i i i can't speak of other
asian countries but this bread this this
country's bread is a joke
like oh yeah this is not like it's not
bread like
no half the bread that you can choose
like i have not seen
a single bread that is like multi-grain
bread like just brown bread right
minding anything but white bread and
then sometimes like bread with custard
in it
who the [ __ ] wants bread with coffee
okay i i [ __ ] with bread
i [ __ ] with it because i grew up eating
that [ __ ] but and then there's other
stuff and it's like
in the uk the one thing that i realized
now i took most for granted
was just a loaf of bread yeah right like
i feel like the one thing that everyone
feels entitled to in the uk is a loaf of
bread
like it is like the staple of the house
right it's just everyone has a loaf of
bread you just go to
like [ __ ] tesco's waitress at most
you can even get the cheaper option
still a whole loaf of bread for like 80
cents
yeah yeah 80 cents adm whatever how many
loaves of bread
how many slices of bread do you get in
the you get like 12 like 12 times you
get a full load like this yeah yeah yeah
yeah
okay japan you get half the [ __ ] loaf
and they've cut it
you get six slices you get six slices
but it's not only six slices it's like
a brick of [ __ ] like it's not even a
slice like it's too thick to make a
sandwich out of
it's so thick that the toaster struggles
to toast it all the way through
you have to like put that [ __ ] in for
like 10 minutes and it's like lightly
brown and i'm just like
i just want toast yeah i think bread has
been the thing that i've
missed the most if not that cheese like
oh don't get me started you can get good
cheese here but
for the same block of cheese in the uk
like a kilogram of cheese i would pay
like two three pounds right so that's
like what four five bucks
here if i want like 200 grams or 500
grams of good
like actual cheese not that god-awful
[ __ ] they have here
it's like 15 bucks like and i'm not
paying that much for cheese because i
just can't like in my head
i mean it's a bigger struggle for me
like considering that australia is like
known for its cheese like all
supermarkets in australia have an
aisle specifically right here you have
to go to a specific
specialized supermarket for foreign
yeah yeah and it's like the most
processed [ __ ]
americans they'll have they'll have like
100 meters of tofu
don't you worry about it they'll have
every every single tofu imaginable
they'll have like it's the same tofu but
with like it's like instead of zero zero
zero zero f on the color grade it's zero
zero zero point one x
one shade whiter literally like the [ __ ]
they'll sell
but like cheese no way get that [ __ ] out
of here we don't need cheese you know
what's [ __ ] when we have more
variations of natto than we do
i mean not that i'm complaining but yeah
i don't know how you handle natto man
i just grew up with a man like this yeah
i'm open to things
yeah i'm i i think i have a really good
like palette i can eat anything
but natto i don't know what the [ __ ] i
don't want to be that guy but it's an
acquired taste
you know you can say that again you know
i i feel that i'm pretty international
and and
i'm open to trying new things there's
there's a few things in the world that i
just don't get
natto is one of them yeah i'm sorry to
betray my own country
durian is another one i'm sorry guys
i've never tried right now
but i've always wanted to what what are
some like
i guess what we're talking about what
are some misconceptions about japan that
you think you experienced
because for me i know i thought for some
reason i thought i was going to eat way
more fish
by just being i mean in comparison i
guess i do eat slightly more fish
all right uh but i thought fish was
going to be way more of a factor in my
life than it actually is
i don't know and i i feel like if you
want to avoid fish in japan it is so
easy
oh yeah like it is i mean i think that
also
comes from the whole fact that like
because there are more foreigners living
here like they were just like
especially like even in between the four
years that i've been living here there
are
so many more vegetarian and vegan places
open now like
it's incredible especially in tokyo but
like
yeah no i agree like i love me my fish
don't get me wrong i'm saying
but i'm definitely not going to eat
sushi every week like most of my fans
think i yeah
i can't eat sushi every day it's like a
it's like a like nice little treat
right right i know what you guys doing
about if i could eat sushi every week i
would and i do most
mostly before pre-quarantine like
because
going to like this dollar sushi chain
yeah i [ __ ] love it because you get
you get better sushi than you do for
paying
30 quid oh yeah i think i think sushi
[ __ ] dollar and it's [ __ ] amazing
and i i do eat quite a lot of fish
mostly because i
eat sushi a lot and when you cook at
home um
you know because i love [ __ ] salmon
yeah
yeah yeah and and because there's so
much fish like in the uk sometimes you
could get like
meat that's been like like seasoned
already yeah and you can get like fish
and supermarkets here that's already
been like
pre-seasoned everything so literally all
you gotta do is open that bad boy up
throw in a pan
and you've got an amazing taste yeah
it's so good i think it's just habit
basically yeah because if you don't have
the habit of eating fish you could
there's there's so many other [ __ ] that
you could eat because there's it's so
readily available pizza potato that's
the best
don't know what pizza potato is come to
japan it's amazing it's
i [ __ ] but that's the thing right
it's like sorry
i think most people think that like oh
we just you know all the receipts it's
just like sushi is
because like you know as as obvious as
this is going to sound japanese
food culture is just so much more than
that like it's so much more than fish
i have consistently had the best italian
food
here as opposed to there would be some
there would be
someone italian out there just like
cringing yeah
you know going to italy it's no contest
right but compared to the uk where
it was literally like again it was a
coin toss right you'd go to a place
and the pastor was like god awful like
it's the saddest carbonara which you
know
how can you [ __ ] that up that's like
pasta 101 right
you come here and i feel like you just
always consistently have like a good
experience with every kind of food right
like i mean i mean you you know this
chinese food in the uk is a joke
we're not gonna
any kind of cuisine you can imagine
except maybe like
american food like really like dinosaurs
yeah like meat like really like ribs and
stuff
yeah it's hard to get that but you know
i'm fine with going to america or going
back to the uk and having that myself
every now and then yeah
for the for the overall trade-off of all
right consistently i get better meals
right yeah right right
is there anything else that like haven't
met your expectations or
haven't met your preconceptions yeah i
would i want to know as like a non-like
president right or like you know
non-japanese this is gonna sound dumb as
[ __ ] right and i know it's gonna sound
dumb but
i like i knew things were going to be
difficult that i couldn't speak japanese
or read japanese more so read than
anything i feel like you can
for some reason you can be fine not
speaking japanese here but if you can't
read
like you're in for like a storm of
trouble because
there are so many things and and i think
you you all can agree on this if amazon
didn't exist here and happen
oh my god if amazon didn't have english
settings here i genuinely don't know
what i would do because
the websites here in japanese like i
don't know if they've done this on
purpose
or due to the old interface they do not
work well with google translate it's all
going back to that like 90s web browser
they don't know how to design their
websites it's not user friendly so if
you can't speak japanese or read
japanese you're kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah
and
the google translate does not help no it
doesn't help it can help you like
feel like you kind of feel your way
through but you cannot tell what the
[ __ ] you're doing
the only reason we've been able to get
through it is because we've had
uh friends we've got a company helping
us yeah that makes it so much
easier for you oh yeah joey shout out to
your friends yeah
joey helped me a lot when i when we
moved here like help me out doing all
the
i had to go to the town hall with you
like fill out your papers
that's the thing right is that you think
like in the
big population areas they'd have like a
lot of english support but i think they
said like if you come
on these certain days like setting up
internet do you remember how much of a
hassle that was good
like i remember that uh uh au right they
say they have an english location in
shinjuku oh yeah
that's a [ __ ] lie no no their english
location
is that they have a tablet which can
call a call center
that can translate the person for you
kind of but not really but that's the
closest thing did you
get that fox i didn't even get to the
guy on the tablet i just turned up
saying
on the website this says this is the
last location and they were like
no and i'm like what do i do how the
[ __ ] do i get internet yeah yeah help me
like i luckily i had a cousin who worked
in japan so she could speak japanese she
helped me through
so much and i don't know what i would do
without her yeah
and you know same with you yeah you
needed like you need a lot of you feel
like a baby
i i genuinely don't know like how
there are some foreigners here who can't
even speak english
yeah somehow at least on their own and
i'm like
how the [ __ ] did you do that because at
least they have a lot of english words
right and a lot
a lot of english options sometimes yeah
if you speak
you can't speak english [ __ ] i don't
know what i don't know how i don't know
like english is hard enough as it is
yeah you know if you can't speak
japanese
then i i think you're pretty much [ __ ]
um if you can't
real positive message coming out of this
episode no no no no
because that's the thing a lot of people
don't talk about which is
how hard it is to live here actually
live here
without speaking japanese because coming
in
like we said it's so different living
here as
you know working here and just live
visiting here as a tourist yeah yeah
there's there's a world of difference
and there's so many little things
like for example registering with a town
hall yeah how the [ __ ] am i supposed to
do that if i don't speak japanese
because they don't they don't speak
english and all the forms were in
japanese yeah the forms they tell you
that you need to do that within two
weeks of moving here yeah or also
in it's just in japanese just learn
japanese in the two weeks that you hear
the only reason we knew is because the
lawyers told us hey you've got to do
this
but like if we didn't know that i don't
know what i was getting i would have
just carried on
you need a dedicated agency just to help
you with all the admin stuff because i
mean i can understand the language and i
still have to like learn from like my
cousins who leave here that's like
oh [ __ ] i have to go to the town hall
and register for like my
address and like my health certificate
and all of that [ __ ] like
yeah i i never had to experience that
living in australia yeah i never had to
experience that while visiting here
right so it's just it's it's
overwhelming and like
i it's like massive kudos to people who
don't know japanese or even don't know
english
yeah again i don't know how the [ __ ]
they do without the help of an agency
like
so to clarify you can live here if you
don't speak any japanese or if you're
learning but
i i think if you're somehow coming here
alone without anyone
helping you it's going to be hell yeah
yeah yeah cause it was hell enough
with multiple ways of us having help
right it was just
and i felt so bad for joey the amount of
times i have to ask him for help i was
like he [ __ ] hates me at this point
every day every day i'm coming over with
a form
what does this say and then also like
until you figure this out right if you
miss a package in the post
you get a little form through your
mailbox that's all in japanese
and and you need to figure out how the
[ __ ] you're going to reschedule this
thing
luckily you know there's a like i found
a way eventually which was like scan the
barcode with like whatever thing you
have
yeah it'll take you to a website use
google translate to translate it
and then hope that the translations are
rough enough where you can like figure
out what's being said and that's what i
do every time now but
for the first week where i didn't know
that every time i missed a package i was
like
hey joey can you uh call them up and
tell them tell them i'm gonna be
homeless it was like a month where like
i was calling up these guys more often
for his packages than i was for my own
packages
i felt so bad but i was like i need the
package
and again like if okay let's trace it
back again
and i hate being like nice to a trillion
dollar company like amazon but
without them and like the english
because you can just change it to
english right yeah they also they have
support in english i'd know because i've
had to like return items and stuff
like it's literally no different from
using like
amazon in in the uk except maybe
sometimes the translations don't work
one for one but
you can pretty much find what you want
like you can type it in english i mean
we basically furnished our entire yeah
my whole house
using amazon yeah because like they they
have like a japanese like here which is
called nitori
um but you know you have to go to the
store you have to register you have to
put in your address
and all that stuff takes like 20 days to
deliver anything yeah
yeah how crazy is that like if you want
to like their version of like
this ikea here as well but it's very
expensive uh
if you buy stuff from nitori which is
like their version of ikea like you said
it's it's like there's a lot there's a
lot of waiting time like 20 days i think
for some products
yeah and i was like i can't wait 20 days
for a bed like i want to sleep
like what do you what do you mean let me
just live on the hard floor
what am i going to do and yeah just uh
also any advice to someone moving to
japan
please make sure your house has ac
before you move in because i didn't
and i had to pay i think it's like two
thousand yeah your previous tenant like
jacked the [ __ ] he [ __ ] gutted the
whole place
he took everything he took the light
bulbs who leaves who takes light bulbs
oh yeah that's a frequent occurrence
you'll see like going into a new
apartment
there won't be any lights right right
you have to apply your own lights like
when i move out of a place i'll leave
stuff that i think is like
super generic that like you don't need
to think about like i'll just
you know i'll i'll leave the bulbs in if
i have like a door mat i'll just leave
the door mat like
whatever they can throw it away if they
don't want it yeah like they they took
everything
everything so i removed everything i
moved in with no ac
and it was getting really cold and i
think there's one cosplay video
where i was like [ __ ] freezing during
this video
and i was getting like naked for it and
i was like
not only that but you were in like the
coldest routine yeah yeah yeah exactly
the
tommy yeah the time which retains no
just like before you move just like
please before you move into an apartment
please make this sure there's ac there
otherwise that's going to be a huge cost
when you move so i had to pay
2 000 plus dollars for two ac units
jesus and
i don't know what i'm gonna do with that
if i haven't moved back to the uk like i
just like
i just can't i guess i'll bring it right
uk could use ac
but like okay let's see you pay for an
apartment right you you paid for the ac
in that apartment right like that's part
of your bill whereas i had to pay
2 000 independently so that you could
argue that my rent has gone up yeah yeah
it's just like dumb [ __ ] like that i
didn't consider no so
okay one thing that was different for me
is how much
i thought i would go to akihabara versus
how much i
actually go to akihabara yeah yeah
because every time we haven't gone since
you guys moved
i know i mean i'm so sad like because i
remember
like when every time we visited here on
holiday we'd spend
half our time there or something like
that of course going to akihabara it's
the proper way to be experienced i'm not
proud to admit that
i it was like it was like the like
imagine every single anime convention
shoved into one it is like a mecca of
weed it is just
the holy land for yeah but then you move
here and you're like
man akihabara is not only a long way
away but you can get a lot of [ __ ]
better online
for cheaper if you can figure out
japanese not only that but there are
just like cities that
just are better for like all-round like
experiences like that's why i love like
ikebukuro yeah yeah
because with akihabara you only go there
for anime yeah if you don't if you want
to do something else then it's
not the best place to go but if you go
somewhere like ikebukuro you can still
shop for anime figurines you can still
go you know go
go down autumn road exactly exactly go
go to the animate there which is also in
akihabara yeah but then you could also
go to an izakiya afterwards or go
karaoke or you know
a lot of other things it's a lot more
varied there's a lot more variation
outside of akihabara than um
if you want just not to downplay
akihabara though no it's amazing don't
like it
no like you every weeb should go to
akihabara yeah
it's an experience you'll have a
spiritual awakening when you go dark but
it is crazy like the first time you go
there yeah holy [ __ ]
why this is what i dreamed about three
sega arcades
right next to each other why it's just
kind of like information overload right
you get blasted with so many lights with
so so much [ __ ] just around you you
don't know where to go
you can spend an entire [ __ ] day in
one store
oh yeah yeah easily because if you want
to look for deals right and figures
you've got to pull out the whole
shelf because they they hide [ __ ] like
way in the back and sometimes you might
find that one deal that is like all you
[ __ ] talk about yeah
when i found that one thing for like 20
bucks yeah if you want to get a figurine
for like the best price
you got to like create like a google
spreadsheet all right this store has it
for this price but the store down there
so you gotta like keep track of
everything yeah and then you ultimately
realize that it's not it's cheaper than
on uh yeah
it's like a price like it's way better
to buy online yeah even amazon here like
the figures are way cheaper sometimes in
the stores which is like weird see
because for me like amazon
itself was just like a huge revelation
because we don't have amazon in
australia yeah wow you don't know
what to think that we have how does a
country function
amazon we have ebay and we have like our
own version of amazon one called
gumtree which is just like oh we have
gum trees yeah yeah yeah yeah
i used to like sell sketchy stuff to
like that's like the craigslist of
amazon though yeah
pretty much but like gumtree i'm pretty
sure it's an australian company
yeah and like so we have gumtree and
ebay and that's it we don't have amazon
so like when
you know back when i was living in
australia and talking to like american
like youtuber friends who were like oh
yeah i just got that off amazon i'm just
like
yeah about that they're selling it for
three times the price on ebay does that
count
i hated it so when i moved here amazon
was just like
whoa holy [ __ ] it's gonna arrive
deliberately yeah [ __ ] hell yeah so
that was amazing
because the thing about akihabara i feel
it's more of an experience
than the actual you don't go there to
actually shop you go there for like the
akihabara experience because yeah like i
remember one of the biggest things that
i noticed going to akihabara is that you
can walk into one shop
and you think it's like this single
store shop and you're just gonna come in
and come out
and then it turns out to be seven
[ __ ] stories
of shops and then you waste
five hours there because there's so much
stuff in this one shop
it's so tightly packed yeah oh by used
figures as well like
their version of used here is is a joke
no everything is immaculate it's
immaculate like i feel bad now because
when i use something it's
[ __ ] messy as [ __ ] i have books that
have like one single folded page or
something that i like
placed it down wrong and that that's
just unusable here yeah they'll be like
damaged goods
looks very used and i'm like what the
[ __ ] used in the uk is like
if it's just barely functioning yeah
yeah it's fairly functioning
you know it probably has like an std i
don't [ __ ] know what it's been
through
whereas here it's like have you opened
the box yeah
yeah which is which is [ __ ] amazing
how connor you found probably the only
used product in japan
which was your fridge oh yeah can we
talk about that
yeah i'll let you tell the story but it
definitely was not in
immaculate shape you know we had spent a
lot of money on moving right
as anyone knows moving is very expensive
uh
and i've heard of these like sayonara
sales as they're called people who move
from japan
they basically sell all their stuff yeah
you know and so they sell their stuff on
craigslist and meline kept telling me
that a bookwalker kept telling me like
dude just buy a buy all your stuff on
craigslist it's like dirt cheap
and i thought well you know it's a great
idea maybe well call her out call her
out
yeah and uh you know i thought all right
well you know japanese people are really
great with like
keeping their stuff immaculate so yeah
uh i order i speak to someone on
craigslist the sauna fridge
and a laundry machine is that what you
call it
i bought it for like it was like 50
bucks right for a fridge and a long like
that's already a red ride right right
but there was some people who were
giving their stuff away for free
yeah yeah because they were like we're
gonna get charged by the the
local council oh yeah yeah to get rid of
the stuff so i didn't pay for anything
else not the moving fear or anything
so you were there with my house when it
turned up yeah like a guy from like new
zealand
yeah he was the kiwi yeah he just turned
up and he was like all right i'll [ __ ]
yeah i'll [ __ ] install the uh
the machine is that your kiwi accent
yeah it's just like
[ __ ] i [ __ ] installed it for you
so he was like i'll swap for you and i
think i discussed with the person on
craigslist they were going to show us
like a tenner for installing yeah so the
guy was like oh no [ __ ] it mate
so he installed it and then like i got
like you remember i got like like
angry [ __ ] texts off the person off
craigslist they were like bombarding my
phone
i picked up the phone and then there was
like an indian woman shouting at me
being like why didn't you pay him the
thousand yen and i was like what the
[ __ ] shut up like
because he said it was cool like he said
it was fine why are you [ __ ] spamming
my phone
i was like yeah and so i was like i was
just like hang up the phone i was like
yeah no he left now what the [ __ ] you
want me to do
yeah yeah what am i supposed to do stop
shouting at me i'm like and i told her i
messed up
if you sent me one more message shouting
at me i'm blocking you
and then they're giving that a hard
block yeah i was like i'm gonna block
you don't you [ __ ] dance
and the the guy uh the the kiwi
uh called me up and he's like all right
mate lucinia she wants the money i'm
gonna come back and get it and then i
was like all right fine
i'll just give you the tanner i don't
care can you just all stop calling me
yeah yeah
i just wanna like enjoy my evening yeah
sorry i
met him at the combini gave him the
tenner and then you know went back yeah
next day i opened my fridge there's like
five cockroaches
in my fridge it was like i was like holy
[ __ ] right no wonder they didn't want to
foreign
imagine being the only foreigner in your
building and that guy has cockroaches
it's like the cleanest country in the
[ __ ] world
i swear to god the [ __ ] who brought
cockroaches
so i bought a cockroach but i i [ __ ]
tore this fridge apart right yeah
i literally told you know like the felt
that you have on fridges though yeah
yeah i tore all that [ __ ] off
i took everything out i bleached the
[ __ ] out of this thing like
this my house must have smelt like a
murder scene
right i bleached the hell out of this
thing and it was the most vile thing
like you know the the felt thing right i
was shaking it out and like maybe like
100 cockroaches must have fell out
i don't even want to know the living
conditions of the person who sold me
this fridge but [ __ ] you
if you ever watch this you are horrible
do not sell people your fridges if they
are
like how can you get cockroaches in the
most cleanest country
that i've ever been to you're on the
streets here and you don't see
any [ __ ] rubbish there are less
cockroaches in like the back of like a
[ __ ] denny's yeah
then they were in your friends yeah like
i i so that was my first experience
buying used in japan
yeah and it was awful because i i just
thought like god damn it like i just got
this house and i have cockroaches now
yeah yeah and so i had to like scour my
whole apartment just making sure these
cockroaches didn't go anywhere
and i and like months after i kept
finding one or two and i'm like
how i bleached everything like there is
no reason these things should be
existing as cockroaches one-on-one make
sure
you thought you got rid of them all this
still around so now i got rid of the
fridge because i just thought enough is
enough this thing looks
disgusting i threw it out yeah it wasn't
a nice looking freezer it was great it
looked like
it looked like something got like a
homeless man with stapler your apartment
probably has a cockroach infection that
you just put into
no no no no no it's it's i got it it's
it's somewhere in the building i got
them one
i got all those [ __ ] i'm just saying
i spent i spent a lot of time that's
what you think
so before we we end this episode i'd
like to know
like especially from you because i know
i experienced this like yeah when you
announced that you moved to japan
because i kept mine secret for like a
month yeah yeah yeah yeah
i didn't tell anyone about the process
and he already told close friends but
like
just kind of dropped it down like i just
kind of like made a tweet being like
live in japan now
what's up everyone's like what like what
reaction did you experience when you
tweeted that i mean everyone just
assumed
that i was you know i was following that
weeb dream that's
that we we talked about earlier where
just like oh you're
you're funny you're finally being the
final form of
every weeb you're finally in japan
you're going to watch so much anime
you're basically japanese
you know everyone assumes i could
already speak japanese because i was
moving to japan
really yeah yeah yeah people people
no no no no no no no i think i think a
lot of people
just rightfully just okay they're not
rightfully i don't know i i would never
assume if someone moves to a country
they can automatically speak the
language but yeah
i got so many comments people mean like
but you can't speak japanese
so like why why would you move there and
i'm like i'm like i don't really it's
not really that much of an issue like
i'm gonna learn it
yeah yeah yeah but it it it did become
an issue and it we it is an issue if we
didn't have someone to help you
it is an issue but like if you have you
know
agency or friends it's not a requirement
yeah if you have amazon
jeff bezos shout out
is that all you got like everyone just
assumed you're like the weeb dream etc
yeah i mean i didn't get too much of
like a reaction apart from just
everyone was happy for me um everyone
like wanted to know how i moved here or
like what i went through
yeah exactly now you know much of much
of the advice i can offer
isn't too helpful because we were kind
of the first of our kind we were like
one of the first
some of the first youtubers to be able
to move here for being an annie tuber
you know
basically we got so good at being a weeb
the japanese government allowed us to
continue being weaves and we're being
paid
they gave us a visa for being a super
[ __ ] weeb
yeah yeah that's pretty much that's like
a you know we're the anomaly we're we're
the exception
yeah in terms of i mean aki technically
was you know no she was she was the
first
i'm saying like we're one of them yeah
of course
of course yeah no it's it's kind of
incredible how i mean i felt the same
way with argue but with you guys as well
that like wow
like attitude has gotten to that point
now yeah yeah yeah cause like
like you know even like three years ago
yeah it was [ __ ] unheard of
yeah right it's like oh yeah you talk
about anime on the internet for a living
yeah yeah good luck staying in your
country for the rest of your life right
but like now it's just like an actual
viable like career option if you can
give back more than you take out yeah
there's no reason why
i guess a government agency would not
want to have that job there right yeah
if you're giving more money and you're
not doing any harm and you're respectful
like why wouldn't they want you yeah
yeah it's
it's been really humbling to like
actually
be working here officially yeah yeah
doing anime youtube and it's it's been
really weird
um especially talking to people who work
in the companies
you know what i mean yeah it's like
directly yeah how do you feel like your
careers have been affected after moving
here
i mean i'm i think mine's like increased
dramatically because now i do have
access directly
to a lot of these like yeah productions
like i i
like you know i knew like a lot of
people in the industry quote unquote
while i was living in australia industry
industry but like it is
a completely different story when you
move here oh no exactly because like
most of these japanese companies don't
know what the [ __ ] email is
no no and they they need they require
you to meet interviews oh no no like
yeah if you're going to do business in
japan you need to have a face-to-face
meeting
no email no [ __ ] zoom call no no
not even a phone call it's like you need
to come to our office and we need to
make sure that you're a real person yeah
exactly
exactly so it's it's it's it's all very
traditional here so to do business with
any anime company which is why
you know things move so slowly is that
you have to follow the tradition you
have to do that face-to-face meeting
they
they call a meeting for any [ __ ]
reason yeah exactly
somebody sneezed in the office when you
discuss whether this is a potential
anthrax injection get hr on the phone
yeah yeah
i mean career-wise i guess for me the
biggest thing is that like
i just want to experience something else
and also you know maybe learn another
language
yeah yeah although it's it's painfully
difficult to learn japanese
um i just think getting more life skills
can can only be a plus right like
if i continue doing what i was doing in
the uk i was doing a lot of voice over
which sure i could probably go and maybe
go into that when i'm
yeah for some reason i stopped doing
youtube but i think i just want to learn
more skills in my life well i'm still
young as well right and while i'm still
open to doing things and putting myself
out there
yeah yeah and i think if anything from
my career definitely like
that benefit of hopefully learning more
and making new connections with
you know maybe not the industry i don't
know what i'll go into but
i mean we've definitely made connections
as well just from being in a company
under
not even in the anime industry just like
lots of industries you made people with
that you never knew that you were a lot
of creatives right yeah a lot of cool
people
like i think the biggest barrier is like
the language barrier yeah yeah
japanese really needs to fix their
difficulty curve because you go from
[ __ ] playing animal
crossing when you're about to do the
eternal on nightmare
it's like like katakana and hiragana is
like you're
just playing animal crossing and then
suddenly you're doing like a no hit um
no hit run in dark souls or something
when kanji gets in and you're like
pretty much what the [ __ ] is going on
this is not the difficulty curve i
wanted and the problem is with like
kanji at least not problem i mean it's
it's really beautiful like the system of
writing i've come to appreciate it more
and more but it's like
if you don't understand a baseline
amount you just can't read anything
yeah because the moment you do you're
like what's wrong welcome to the past 25
years of my life right
right and it's like it's not like you
know if i was learning french where i
can sound it out and maybe like
i just can't like i'm like what the [ __ ]
is that thing and then you're like oh i
know what this kanji is
turns out the kanji has five different
pronunciations and meanings
and you don't know which one's which
because you you just have to know that
[ __ ]
it's just [ __ ] that's that's i think
that's what's the most difficult right
is that like japan is like an
anti-phonetic country right yeah yeah
yeah you just have to know it
and that's why it's so difficult for a
lot of people i mean like i mean
i think i we know a lot of people who
can speak japanese but have not even
attempted to learn to reject no no no it
is
a completely different ballgame you know
like even like
me having learnt it but pretty much my
first language
i still struggle with it every now and
then it is like a constant learning
process for me
yeah and like thank god that my mom did
whip my ass to like loner when i was
little because jesus christ my life has
been
a million times easier that i can read
it and understand it but
it's the one time when she said you
appreciate it when you're older yeah you
did actually appreciate it when you're
older thanks mom
you helped build my career essentially
yeah everyone said that with welsh
didn't quite pan out i mean i appreciate
the culture but that's uh about as far
as a usefulness
but here's the question i want to ask
you guys how well now that you've
experienced living here for what like
eight
months essentially seven eight months
now how long do you intend to stay here
um that's a good question i i think i've
lived here long enough to know that
i don't want to live here forever right
yeah i think there's just
at least right now and how japan is a
lot of stuff that i just like don't
gel with yeah yeah um i think i can
definitely see myself
because i put a lot of time though yeah
yeah because i i've lived here for eight
months it feels it's felt like i've
lived here for a month
right i haven't even reached a service
close to my final form
like i want an anime reference i know
we've hardly talked about anime on this
podcast
but uh yeah i mean i still like i feel
like i've
i want to explore japan more i want to
learn the language way more proficiently
than
than i have now um i want to take
advantage of it way more and i want to
experience japanese cultures more
because the one thing i the one thing
the one way
the one target i've set myself i should
say is being able to
like have a conversation with some of
the businesses and you know going to
some of the office parties
actually being able to participate in
the conversations and everything like
that
um that's like my goal when it comes to
learning you know yes same i just want
to be able to communicate yeah um
and learn a bit of kanji right learn the
basics just so i can like figure out
you know what the mcdonald's menu says
yeah i mean like
yeah it's uh i can definitely see it
being like a second home to me
right like a place where maybe i can
easily go back to it months periods but
i think like when i'm like 50 or
whatever i think i'm gonna miss the
how because i think i've been you know
i've been really ingrained in british
culture of like how friendly and open it
is
yeah i really like that like yeah
especially in wales you just rock up to
a pub and you can speak to anyone there
yeah in the small pubs in wales like i
love that and i kind of missed that a
bit
um and i think yeah i think i i don't
know i mean i'm eight months in maybe in
a podcast in a year
we'll talk about it and our minds will
have changed yeah i want to live here
forever right yeah
yeah yeah i think i think because right
now i feel like a foreigner still
right and i think that's probably never
going to change but maybe at some point
i'll
i'll finally feel like i can call this
place home yeah yeah it might smoothen
out a little yeah
probably i imagine it will unless i get
arrested and convicted of a crime that i
wasn't accused of then i'm imprisoned
for 100 years
but you know what's the odds of that
before we end the podcast yeah there was
like
one story i wanted to end on which is um
like it it completely shattered what my
preconceptions of moving to japan would
be
um and that was at one of the company
parties that we attended
with uh book walker in geeks plus and
you know kadakara in general
and it was to do with my fiance sydney
yeah so what happened was you know we
went to a company party everyone got
pretty merry
and then we went to uh a bar
afterwards right i think
a lot of people from from the company
some some pretty high up from the
company
and then we started singing karaoke
together and so
sydney being the drunken little weeaboo
that she is such
she's such a weirdo unlike us unlike us
she went through her weeb phase right
she went proper cringy weeb face
unlike us i i just i love sydney i love
you should watch this yeah
isn't she like kind of the face of like
the cringy weeb
according to the instagram
so we start singing karaoke and she
starts singing the anna
and hannah and me and god were like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing like you're
in front of a lot of important
people in the company and she starts she
starts
bailing the [ __ ] uh and honey and
hannah ending
and then the [ __ ] businessman start
clapping
and cheering i start singing along
and i i know i'm just sitting there like
we were both shocked i couldn't believe
what i was seeing i looked at connor
and i'm like is this our slash it
already happens right now
are we living our 2007 tumblr posts yeah
like oh yeah yeah so like i i moved to
japan
and uh yeah i was i was in an important
business meeting a business party
and then we started singing the
yanahanna opening uh ending even
and then everyone started clapping and
cheering and it was amazing
i'm like this this is so surreal right
now it's literally
that happened post right it's like this
definitely happened
but it's great because i feel like when
you do sing stuff like that it's never
they're never like oh my god they're
trying to be like us they're like oh my
god they care about our culture that's
so cool they really do yeah and i guess
i guess
that's what i want to end on which is
like i think
it's you know we started on the good
sides and the bad sides of japan but i
think they really do
care about our culture they're really
they really care about learning more
and they are open to foreigners there's
just sometimes
a lot of barriers that come between that
and i guess one of the biggest things
you can do is learn japanese because
that's such a
they love it they love it if you speak
japanese they love it to them it's like
you've made an effort to learn that
yeah i mean and you know likewise right
like if somebody comes over
to like your country and they can
understand your language like that's
immediately like
oh yeah oh yeah if you could speak welsh
in wales like you're immediately like
like love because like what people in
wells welsh can't even speak whales
welsh people can't even speak well right
like it's i can imagine it's like one of
those right yeah
and i think like you said right all
differences aside and all complaints
that we have like at the end of the day
i don't think i've ever spoken to a
person here who's been rude to me
no and everyone has been super nice and
you know you might get stared at or
anything but that's not a place of like
you know
aggression or anything they just they
just don't see it often and yeah at the
end of the day they're
really really nice the positives
definitely outweigh this oh 100 yeah
i mean i i'm just british right so to me
it's like one percent
one percent negative 99 positive i only
see this right that's what your raise is
british
exactly but overall it's it's an amazing
country and i'm glad that we have
i'm having a great [ __ ] time oh yeah
yeah i'm glad you're with the boys
with the boys get to do this [ __ ]
podcast
[Laughter]
yeah so i think that's a good place to
end it so thank you very much for tuning
in to trash taste podcast episode two we
didn't have any twitter questions yet
because episode one hasn't aired as as
of recording this but make sure to go
follow at trashtaste pod
on twitter give us your subreddits oh
yeah we have a subreddit as well yeah
you made it so we have a subreddit my
username is i came for memes don't ask
me why it's a throwaway account i had to
make something so if you don't want to
use twitter you can always hit us up on
our subreddit give us like topic
suggestions questions any of that kind
of stuff
yeah we're good to get more community
involvement yeah exactly absolutely we
can't wait for
this there could because right now it's
just us just [ __ ] talking to each
other like we don't know what's gonna
happen
this is just another [ __ ] friday
night and uh
so yeah we'll see you in episode three
thank you for being such a good host
[Music]
happy birthday to me happy
you